this is not to say that I have no
sympathy for the people of Ukraine but
something else is going on here at this
level right there the people are all at
this level but the machine and the way
it operates and the fakery and the show
and all of that that's up here and
that's what I'm poking fun at right now
uh here is zielinski and his wife posing
for a Vogue photo shoot again one of
these things you would imagine at the
height of a war you have a lot to do
like guys could we move the soldiers
this way do we have enough bullets uh
but you know Vogue photo shoot
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
you may have recognized famous portrait
photographer Annie Leibovitz there she's
the one that took care of that and again
it's just like if you were real like try
to imagine say I don't know Winston
Churchill
Winston Churchill the Nazis are on the
way guys the Nazis are coming excuse me
I'm trying to take a picture for Vogue
okay
how was that for a Churchill
impersonation that was I'm trying to
take a picture for about just a second
ridiculous anyway the meme makers of the
internet had a little fun with that so
take a look
[Music]
God that woman scares me